not even that uh so there's another
article from
the new york post which i i've talked
about quite a bit and it always gets me
in a lot of trouble with the feminists
women are struggling to find men who
make as much money as they do
and look when we have uh jack murphy on
the show and and we had a long
conversation about this
where he was saying that if you're a guy
and you're successful why would you find
a woman your own age
when you could have someone 10 right 15
years younger so you're 35
you know you go for a 22 year old
dedicated housewife doesn't have a
career
and for you know i guess i don't put
words in his mouth but a lot
the idea to a lot of these guys is that
a younger woman
who can get an older man who's
accomplished successful has a lot of
money
it's i mean it's a big leap in access to
resources
and societal status when you've got a
guy who's accomplished well connected
so if you have a woman who is say 30 or
in her 30s
and she's working you know a job she's
making maybe
65 70 000 a year working at a a
publication in new york city a guy who's
the same age who's making that much
money
could probably easily get a much much
younger woman
because that's a lot of money to a
younger person which i imagine must make
it more difficult for
for women yeah that's exactly right so
what do we mean
it's like we gotta we gotta rock and
rolls i guess yeah no that's that's the
issue and so i'm looking toward
gen z and whatever that we're gonna call
the next generation
is that if we don't want that to happen
we don't want to keep women back it's
not like we want to keep girls and women
back from reaching their potential
and contributing to the world what we
want to do is help
raise boys and men to reach their
potential
you are you mentioned femininity earlier
and how it's it's one of the
things that can bring men to their knees
yes and i thought about um proposal
and how men propose from their knees
exactly and it's like
when you're brought to your knees like
why why is that a thing is it because
they were so like broken and desperate
and please be with me forever like
please don't
like is that why they're doing it from
their knees because they're like begging
to god which is the woman
it could be it could be i don't know
where it's the same reason
you know we see you ever see that really
funny video where there's like two birds
and like the female bird looks kind of
normal just like a brown bird or
whatever but the male bird is like jet
black
and it's jumping back and forth dancing
it's like trying to prove
their worth so when the guy gets on his
knees basically saying to the woman
i will never leave you i am on my knees
for you
so you will be safe with me if you get
pregnant
so you mentioned you know evolution a
woman who gets pregnant is at risk
right i mean you're not going to be
running you're not going to be fighting
you need protection right and so the guy
you need to know that the guy
is going to stand up i guess the problem
arises in that we are
the apex predator we kill and eat
basically
everything and in cities the only
predators are other humans
so there's still a need for some
protection but also access to resources
is important now everything's kind of
changing especially with
you know maternity laws you know so
women get pregnant they can keep working
and now a lot of companies are like even
if
once someone gets pregnant she can go
home she can stay home and we'll still
keep paying her
so i think that also we keep moving this
direction
we're going to keep removing the need
for marriage which is going to slowly
eat away at
families having children to result in
slow population growth
seems like it's just dominoes falling
over well in fact
there there is a rise in people living
together couples living together
not getting married and i don't have the
i haven't dug in too deeply into it but
my hypothesis
is again it's a buyer's market for men
that a woman who really wants a baby
with a partner
and he won't commit she will acquiesce
to saying yeah no we're just we're gonna
live together because like it's cool
like
no it's great i mean really what do we
need a piece of paper for
because if not he's going to go to the
next person
right so and this is what's going on in
campus this is what the hookup culture
is about
a girl will you know girls are you know
oh kids are
kids so yeah i am old i'm on campus
the the hookup culture is because there
are so many more girls
than except for maybe mit than men on
campus
and girls doesn't mean anything no we're
just friends no no
but really what she's really saying i
bet is pick me
pick me like let me make let me do
whatever i can to show him how good i am
in bed how much i love him actually i
care about him
but no no it's all cool no don't worry
about it women are acquiescing all the
time
and in fact they're acting like men men
are the ones who spread the seed men are
the ones
who have sex with a lot of women all of
a sudden women are doing it
and i you know i say you know what now i
women don't really want to have sex like
men they want to have sex
like women and what they're doing is
they are
listening to this narrative that in
order to be equal to men
they have to be men and that happens
even when it comes
to sex with 22 year olds it reminds me
of like similar things to what you know
jordan peterson talks about
you know uh women trying to be men it
also reminds me of
like jokes from family guy where they
did one where it's the woman trying to
finish up with all the guys
desperately trying to act like a guy as
if that's what she should be doing
right yeah it's uh not confidence
building
you know everything that's happening but
i i will mention one thing as
as for marriage the only the you know if
there there was
there was one message that was i was
smacked in the head with over and over
again as i was growing up is
do not get married you will regret it
who's
who said that to you married with
children a very the highest rated show
sure uh at the time my parents wouldn't
let us watch it yes
al bundy the main character yeah hated
his wife they hated each other
sad but it's not the only show i i
constantly
you hear this all the time from from
older men they call it the ball and
chain
now what kind of message is that to a
guy then you look at
divorce courts i i i there was there was
a there was a case i think it was in
illinois
where a man and a woman were getting
divorced and
it was partly because of the women's i
think i think was like drug addiction
it's been a long time since i've i've
read the story
the court sided with the mother who was
a known drug addict because
courts have a bias towards the woman and
then she killed her kids
yeah and so the dad who was a regular
working class guy
begged the court this woman has been
arrested before she does drugs it's
dangerous
and they said we can't take a kid away
from from from their mother and then she
ended up killing them because she didn't
want him to have him and then taking her
own life like overdosing
so when you hear these stories all the
time when you constantly hear about how
divorce courts what does it like 84
of the time favor the woman what's the
incentive for a man to
to to marry a woman if all it means for
him
is that he can lose half of his life
and still lose his kids in the long run
why do it it breaks my heart i am
i've certainly dated divorced men and
i've heard
chilling stories um my friend greg ellis
his book is coming out father's day or
that week
called the respondent and it is about
his hellish
experience of being divorced or getting
or
his wife's springing i won't it's it's
literally i
paid like a thriller like it reads like
a thriller the hell
he has gone through and the hell that
men go through i think that for some
reason
everything needs to be equities
everywhere equality is everywhere but
when it comes to family law
it is so incredibly unfair to men and it
sincerely breaks my heart
and to your point it doesn't help women
because it means that a woman can
basically
i mean it's it's really this sort of
believe all women you know idea
philosophy in courts and it breaks my
heart because
men are wonderful there's many bad men
as there are bad women it's not a
i men are fantastic and men do
so much for their families generally so
i'm i'm with you
the but i think that the reason why you
know men
marry women is because they love them
which doesn't mean that things don't
happen
and that you know people don't change or
circumstances
what have you right for whatever reason
people get divorced but i believe in
love
and i believe that a man is better with
a partner and a woman is better
with a partner and what that could be
the same sex
the idea is that we are better when we
have a strong
existential spiritual emotional
mental connection with somebody we do
better in life
and marriage is a strong partnership to
do that
now i have not married not because i
didn't want to
i very much i still want to but i never
wanted to marry a man i wasn't in love
with
because every man deserves to be loved
and i didn't want to be in a
relationship where i didn't feel loved
so i wonder though um
i i was reading well i was writing this
a while ago but i was also reading it
recently that love
love and marriage is a is a modern
construct that marriages used to be
contractual
more more corporate than anything yeah
you had the dowry
and it was basically well you know
marriages are arranged for
that reason and less so you know
in in our culture and going back to the
various cultures that make up the united
states but if you look at a lot of
eastern culture
arranged marriage very much still exists
because it was transactional
sure oh yeah and it was the families did
it i mean sir all the royals are
are intramarried i mean there's no
question
today we don't have to do that maybe
that is a benefit of
there are a lot of benefits of feminism
and that women can now live
toward their potential we have the
opportunity to do more than
be only nurses secretaries nuns and and
teachers
not to say those are all great
professions but we can do more
the difference is that um
now i've just lost my train of thought
you just
oh the marriage so but if a woman wasn't
making any money
then how is she going to find a man like
the men would could just pick any woman
this way if it was arranged at least she
was safe like this was
you know he we're wealthy you have your
you know life standards this man will
make sure that you have a we can do this
you're from the same class the same
religion the same
royal whatever it is so that's part of
it
you know people have this issue with um
with the disney
fairy tales which aren't really disney
fairy tales they're disney fied fairy
tales
and you know talk about like cinderella
etc
well why is the you know why did the
mother die in all of them well the
mother's dead to show kids
first of all that mothers did die young
anyway they died when they were like 30.
um that these girls could be on their
own take care of themselves but
yeah but you know well she married some
prince i'm like listen here's the thing
she had no education no skills
no job opportunities what was she going
to do
the truth is a prince
pretty good deal so yes we have to think
about things that
historically people did things the way
they did them for a reason today
you know that's not what marriage is for
marriage is a partnership
i mean i have a cousin who's uh you know
been co-ceo a fortune 500 company and
her husband worked but not
anywhere near to that level it's not
like it doesn't happen that
you know women can be more successful in
terms of affluence what in income
but for the most part you know
women want to know that the man that
they're with will also enable them to
reach their potential
as he as she would do for him not only
in terms of a job and career but also in
terms of
family in terms of whatever else that
they want to do i think that's the
i think there's there's an incongruity
there's an impasse
you've got i think a lot of men who
want just a wife like you mentioned they
want their moms
yeah so this current generation is just
there's no there's not coming together
it's like it's
if if women are taking on masculine
roles if they're taking jobs
men you know to a great degree to a
higher degree
don't want that right so then it's just
thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time